for more information on tutoring or how
to support moofy university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
so lights or radiant energy or
electromagnetic radiation is energy that
comes as a result of electric and
magnetic fields that's what light is now
back in the day with classical physics
it was thought that energy was wave-like
and that matter was particle like energy
vases a wave and matter behaves as a
particle so light or radiant energy I
mean its energy right so I mean it says
right there right radiant energy so if
its energy then it's a wave must behave
as a wave not quite it behaves as though
it's made of a particles
kind of weird right so it behave as a
wave and as a particle so it has what's
called wave particle duality duel or
duality coming from dual meaning of
course referring to to the two concepts
the two things that it can behave as a
wave and a particle so that's kind of
weird so you might be thinking okay so
what who cares why are we talking about
this weren't we just talking about atoms
and nuclear reactions and things like
that how is light at all related to that
well back in the day at the late 1800s
Early 1900s physicists couldn't really
explain what was going on with subatomic
particles so but their understanding
over time develop slowly to what is now
called quantum mechanics or quantum
theory okay so there's this thing called
quantum theory or quantum mechanics
which kind of explains what's going on
at a subatomic level but in order to
understand what's going on with quantum
theory and quantum mechanics and in
order to better understand what's going
on with the atom we need to discuss
light and understand it and its
properties specifically this idea of
wave-particle duality this is pretty
important okay so we're going to see how
how light kind of works and what its
what's going on with it and eventually
that will transition into quantum theory
quantum mechanics and a better
understanding of the item so I hope that
video was helpful thank you for watching
if you found that video helpful don't
forget to Like comment subscribe and
share with friends thank you and happy
studying